[Musique]
bonsoir
alors moi j'ai une petite question pour
oro est ce que vous vous rappelez de la
première de votre classe terminale
c'est de vous si c'est vraiment vous je
vous demande de prendre quelques
instants et de repenser à votre
comportement classe à cette époque
et si ce n'était pas vouée c'est à vous
le dernier je vous demande de repenser à
cette première de classe de cette époque
la journée quelques secondes et vous
pensez à vous à lui parfois ça arrive et
est ce que vous pensiez comme moi
qu'elle était très énervant de cette
fille
cette fille là était très énervante
toujours assise devant toujours la
première répondre à toutes les questions
à 18 de moyenne dans toutes les matières
en ma 10 8 en philosophie 18 en anglais
18 ans sport bon elle était souvent nul
en sport mais je la trouvais très
énervante et le pire c'est que pendant
les vacances pendant que vous jouez
qu'est-ce qu'elle fait cette fille et
pensons livres de maths et unique tous
les exercices qu'il ya dedans pour se
distraire d'accord et pendant que vous
vous jouer à cache cache avec votre
bulletin de notes
qu'est ce qu'elle fait elle exhibe non
seulement devancé par an merci de m'en
veux par an ou bien vous emmerder et va
pas avancer traître qui n'hésite pas à
dire mais pourquoi tu ne peux pas faire
comme angélique pourquoi tu demeureras
d'aussi belles nantes
elle était vraiment très énervant cette
fille j'étais cette fille j'étais cette
fille là les gens maternelle
j'étais la première de ma thèse en colo
réagi en récitation et aux primaires g
rap et tous les prix d'excellence que je
pouvais arriver au secondaire c'était
pareil de la seconde dans le terminal
major de promo à l'université taille
tous mes professeurs me disait tu seras
joue ministre de la justice du bénin
certains disaient tu seras la plus
grande avocate que ce pays ait jamais
connue et j'y crois j'y croyais je me
sentais vraiment unique en son genre je
me sentais spéciale
j'imaginais ma viande d avignon parle
couramment cinq langues
tutoyant les grands de ce monde mais à
votre avis est-ce que cette histoire
s'est terminée comme mes forces avait il
précisé
non c'est le seul fait pas du tout
terminer comme ça à la sortie de
l'université
eh ben j'ai essuyé trois longues années
de chômage entre wallons avaient rien à
la maison et je peux vous dire que c'est
là que j'ai découvert ce que c'est que
le doute ce que c'est que l'échec ce que
c'est que la peur
vous savez on entend souvent parler des
histoires de steve jobs de mark
zuckerberg des gens qui étaient pas très
bon à l'école et à exceller dans la vie
mais on entend moins parler que mon
histoire est l'histoire de plein
d'autres enfants
on a poussé à exceller en classe et qui
a une fois arrivé dans la vie se sont
retrouvés complètement et muninn et moi
aujourd'hui
j'avais envie de redonner de la voix ces
personnes la chaleur vidéo leur donner
la parole
ils ne parlent pas pourquoi parce qu'ils
ont honte parce qu'ils ne sont pas
devenus ce que la société attendait
d'eux mais je crois que cette histoire
importante non seulement pour leur
redonner du courage mais aussi pour
parler à nos parents et pour leur dire
bonjour sont les plus doués sont
beaucoup plus fragiles que vous ne le
pensez accompagner les suivez l'un ne
laissait pas libre comme si c'était des
robots paraît qu'ils allaient réussir
leur vie
au fait qu'en dit de quelqu'un qu'il est
bon grâce aux petits pas en quoi il est
bon c'est parce qu'il a d'excellentes
notes n'ont fait qu'est-ce que c'est
notre l'a traduit ce mois je pense
qu'elle traduit deux choses la première
c'est qu'un premier de classe est
apparue hérité des concepts et de la
régularité comme un perroquet oui moi
j'étais très fort ça je pourrais vous
citer dépend du conte civic parker
gelais très forte et je connais salami
premier de classe aussi qui provoque des
cris des équations très complexe de
mémoire et tout le monde disait qu'on
était extraordinaire et la deuxième
chose que je pense qu'un premier de
classe fait très bien dans notre pays
c'est sa voix sur les règles vous savez
le prouver de classe qui piquent ceux
qui bavent adjamé en classe ils
dénoncent même ses camarades qui par un
et en plus ça il fait jamais le mur il
ne contredit jamais le professeur
monsieur madame pareil mais en fait
est ce que vous pensez vraiment car une
bonne mémoire
ça va suivre des règles est-ce que ça
suffit ou affronter la vie réelle
ce sont de belles qualités mais ce
qu'elles suffisent pour affronter l'as
verriers
est-ce que vous pensez que vous
prendriez comme avocat quelqu'un qui
sait seulement réciter des textes de
lois de mémoire non évidemment non nous
apprenons en fait à nos premiers de
classe à suivre des règles mais non la
prenons pas du tout en créer de
nouvelles
nous l'apprenons à mémoriser des
concepts mais on la prie ne pas analyser
une situation banale et à donner leur
avis nous l'apprenons quoi nous
l'apprend aucune l'échec c'est grave
nous l'apprenons qu'être en échec c'est
être in intelligent on l'a apprenons à
ne pas prendre de risques
combien de parents ne disent pas tu ne
dois pas faire de sport tu ne dois pas
faire de danse parce que c'est notamment
elle va baisser
nous leur apprenons à se sentir
supérieur aux autres ne fréquente pas ce
petit celui dernier de la classe d'art
et apprendre plutôt qu'à se sentit
complémentaire à eux nous la prenons
toutes ces choses est en fait ce que
nous faisons c'est que nous créions tel
géant aux pieds
argile nous prions nous créons des gens
qu'on était en plein troubles m et qui
ont des jambes qui tangue
le magazine forbes a dit que le projet
les professionnels de demain aura devra
avoir certaines qualités il devra savoir
s'adapter
il devra être polyvalent il devra savoir
communiquer il devrait savoir écouter il
devra savoir s'adapter à la
multiculturalité et je pense que les
premiers de classe dans mon pays ne
possède pas ces qualités et je ne pense
pas le pire en fait c'est que non
seulement il ne les possède pas mais en
plus de ça ils sont convaincus qu'ils
ont tout ce qu'il faut pour affronter la
vie parce que nous leur disons quoi as
tu es tellement intelligents ont tiré
sur a tellement facilement
et peut-être comme me demanderez
maintenant mais qu'est ce qu'il faut
faire est-ce qu'il faut empêcher un
élève d'avoir de bonnes notes
s il faut le forcer à ne pas performé en
place non évidemment ce n'est pas ce que
je dis moi je vais vous raconter mon
expérience
pendant mes années de chômage parce que
ce qui m'a sauvé la vie
ce qui m'a permis de ne pas tomber en
dépression
c'est que je t'aime première de classe
et mes parents il me poussait à
développer mes talents artistiques
je dansais je dessinais qui écrivait et
maman elle me poussait vraiment
alimenter cette passion elle m'a acheté
des livres
elle m'est arrivé à des ateliers
d'écriture j'étais à des ateliers de
deux décès et je pense que pendant
chacune de ses activités
en fait j'ai appris à développer la
résistance à l'adversité
surtout à mon club de danse mon
professeur de danse me détester il me
trouvais très très moche
il me disait de l'aurès tué trop grosse
tu ne l'as pas de sens de la
coordination je ne sais pas ce que tu
fais ici et moi je me disais
intérieurement mais non je me sens bien
quand je danse gym dansée et tu ne
m'empêchera pas de le faire donc j'ai
continué et donc pendant ses années de
chômage je pense que très expériences
ont remonté à la surface
j'ai résisté j'ai résisté la dépression
j'ai résisté à l'humiliation que je
ressens tu es ayant une deuxième chose
je pense que j'ai acquise quand j'étais
enfant pendant mes différentes activités
c'est ma capacité à moto formé en fait
pendant mes ateliers d'écriture me
demandait de dessiner de écrire des
biographies d'un romance des polars je
ne savais pas comment ça s'écrivait et à
l'époque ian par google donc j'allais à
la bibliothèque et je m'instruis they m6
je refusais et pendant la période de
chômage ça m'a aidé parce que j'ai fait
le point de mes lacunes je me suis auto
forme et je me suis inscrit dans un club
d'art oratoire
je suis allé sur internet mais serait
pour apprendra comment planifier
organiser des qualités que je pensais me
manquer et à l'issue de tout ça j'ai ont
fait décrocher mot pro
l'international j'étais tellement
contente
tellement fos rené zé par être payés
j'étais heureuse que mes efforts et
payer alors je dis aux parents qui sont
ici avoir de bonnes notes ce n'est pas
une fin en soi il faut que vous laissez
vos enfants sortis de leur zone de
confort laissez les faire du sport pour
socialiser les 71 des activités
artistiques ou apprendre la créativité
les cds prend soin des plus jeunes à la
maison pour apprendre le sens des
responsabilités laissez les entreprendre
petit job pendant les vacances ou bien
développement petits commerces répondent
à gérer l'argent c'est très important et
j'espère que pendant mon speech vous
avez bien repenser à cette première de
classe où vous avez bien repenser à vous
même si c'était vous et que la prochaine
fois que vous croisez dans la rue
celle qui fut la pouvait de voter à ce
fonds ne la regarderai pas de haut dans
le mouvement que l'ehpad est parce qu en
fait
rappelez vous elle que la victime un
système qui ne comprend pas d'où
challandes ont tort la rencontrerez
petite nuit qui n'est pas trop tard pour
ai dit oui elle peut encore aller à la
rencontre d elle même qu'elle peut
redécouvrir et redevenir l'enfant
qu'elle aurait dû être
qu'elle laisse pas ses possibilités ses
envies qu'elle danse qu'elle dessine
qu'elle écrive quelques-uns des links
pourquoi pas en tout cas depuis qu'il
n'est pas trop tard pour elle et que
tout ira très très bon
[Applaudissements]